the metroid franchise has a sprawling
timeline that weaves its grand sci-fi
saga across 11 mainline games but how
does everything tie together well not
neatly to be honest you might have
noticed metroid dread referred to as
metroid 5 despite the fact that it's
actually the 11th entry in the franchise
and that's not even including metroid
prime pinball you see metroid dread
marks the conclusion of a story arc
dating back 35 years which takes in the
original metroid metroid 2 return of
samus super metroid and metroid fusion
hence you know metroid 5. but that
chronology doesn't even take into
account the metroid prime trilogy and
its various handout spin-offs or even
metroid other m so with metroid red set
to expand the canon and conclude samus's
long-standing mission to exterminate the
metroids what better time to recap the
franchise's entire story and if you like
these kinds of deep dives into gaming
timelines please make sure to like this
video and subscribe to the channel it
really helps us out right from samus's
confrontation with mother brain through
to the horrors of being pursued by the
sax in metroid fusion this is the
complete timeline of the metroid
franchise
[Music]
all right to really dive into the story
of metroid you need to go back to the
origins of its iconic central character
sama saran while the games rarely delve
into her tragic backstory there's
actually a lot to dig into especially if
you've read the manga volumes telling
her tale which if you're interested in
those good luck because they're
absolutely impossible to find save for
the first two chapters which you can
read for free on the metroid database
right where was i oh yeah i'll be brief
because the manga covers a lot volume 1
sees samus have her first encounter with
the wise chozo bird people and come face
to face with ridley and the space
pirates who promptly kill her parents
and destroy her homeworld volume 2
however largely details samus's training
at the hands of the chozo on their home
world of zebes her time in the galactic
federation and her ongoing battle with
mother brain who is revealed to be a
super computer created by the chozo
remember this is all before the first
game in the franchise even takes place
speaking of which volume 2 dovetails
nicely into the opening of that game
[Music]
naturally the og metroid or its remake
zero mission if you will kicks off our
timeline in earnest the year is 20x5 in
the cosmic calendar and space pirates
have attacked a deep space research ship
making off with mysterious organisms
known as metroids their plan to breed
the metroids and use them as biological
weapons to wage war on the galaxy
standing in their way are the galactic
federation space cops they send in
renowned bounty hunter samus aaron to
infiltrate the planet and take down
mother brain the main antagonist behind
the space pirates galaxy conquering plot
and that's just the prologue to samus's
zero mission a whole load of story
information that isn't even mentioned in
the game and you'll probably only see if
you're at the game's manual which if
you're anything like me age 12 you
probably didn't either way the game
kicks off with samus landing on zebes
and she begins to explore the chozo
ruins she infiltrates zebes then
encounters and destroys a host of mother
brains lieutenants including the giant
reptilian crade think king k rool on
steroids
and her old nemesis the egotistical
space dragon ridley oh and a metroid son
of metroids finally she comes face to
face with mother brain herself who she
promptly dispatches before escaping the
planet and that's where the original
metroid finished but zero mission added
on an extended epilogue that saw samus
attacked by space pirates as she left
the planet of zebes this redux ending
saw samus crash land back on the planet
near to the space pirates mother ship
with her iconic power suit completely
destroyed left in just her zero suit
samus infiltrated the mothership before
discovering the nearby ruins of chazodia
an ancient chozo site where she
discovered a fully charged power suit
samuston's the power suit which we
learned was originally created by the
chozo and makes her way out of the ruins
carving her way through hordes and
hordes of space sparrows on route before
she can escape though she's cornered by
mecca ridley a robot designed by ridley
in his own image i did say he was
egotistical naturally samus destroys
mecca ridley and escapes before the
mothership self-destructs destroying all
of the space pirates research on the
metroids
[Music]
all right before we go on there's a
little confusion as to where the metroid
timeline goes next as there's a few
inconsistencies within the in-universe
dates for the rest of the franchise but
the metroid prime sub-series of games is
largely thought to squeeze into the
timeline between metroid zero mission
and metroid 2 samus returns as metroid's
are largely running a mock before samus
exterminates them all in metroid 2.
obviously more on that later metroid
prime kicks off in a suitably
action-packed way with samus responding
to a distress signal from an unknown
frigate which is orbiting the planet of
talon 4. surprise surprise it's a space
pirate research facility where the
reptilian race are experimenting with a
bizarre substance known as faison found
in abundance on talon 4. samus
infiltrates the facility before being
attacked by the parasite queen who
promptly brings the frigate crushing
down to the planet's surface a maneuver
that sees samus lose all of her
abilities in one fell swoop this will
become a trend as you'll see going
through the games samus makes her way
down to the surface of talon 4 in
pursuit of the space pirates and begins
to explore her new surroundings she soon
discovers the remains of a chozo
settlement and ominous warnings about a
great poison the aforementioned faison
an element so dangerous that it's
destroyed the chozo civilization on the
planet she slowly pieces together the
chozo's tragic backstory learning that
they locked away this evil substance
within the core of the planet and
devised a trixie set of riddles for
anyone that came looking for it namely
those bastard space pirates eventually
samus cracks the chozo riddles and as
she's about to descend into the bowels
of the planet she's attacked by
meta-ridley a reborn enhanced version of
the ruthless space dragon that's not to
be confused with mecca ridley the
metallic form of the ruthless space
dragon who we saw at the end of zero
mission i started playing these games
well over 20 years ago and that's the
first time i've realised that they're
two different things yeah that's on me
either way samus makes short work of the
giant lizard before making her way down
into the centre of talon 4. down there
she discovers the titular metroid prime
a super enhanced metroid who's been
feasting on phase on the entire time and
after a prolonged boss battle that makes
use of every arm cannon and every visor
upgrade you can get in the game the
metroid prime is no more but wait what's
that yeah if you 100 of the game a
little post-credit sting way before
marvel made them popular showcased a
hand emerging from the ooze of the
faison a tease that will catch up to
very shortly but first a little detour
yeah let's park that epic phase on
narrative at the main prime games for a
while as it's time for a little slice of
handheld metroid
in the form of the nintendo ds's metroid
prime hunters hunters sees samus jet off
to the far flung reaches of the tetra
galaxy to the home of the now extinct
olympics which are basically this game's
chozo why are they extinct well it's one
of the metroid galaxy's many mysteries a
mystery that starts to unravel when a
host of nefarious bounty hunters chief
among them a lad called psylux more on
him later start receiving messages from
within the olympic cluster about a
secret to the ultimate power with a view
to stopping that mysterious ultimate
power falling into the wrong hands the
galactic federation sends samus to
secure any potential threats turns out
this ultimate power is all a hoax set up
by the all-round wronger named guerrilla
who's trying to break free from the
ubeliet and old olympic prison geez i
feel like i just hallucinate that last
sentence uh either way samus squares up
to the space inmate and escapes the
prison facility before it self-destructs
in a finale that brings metroid prime
hunters to a close
right back to that tantalizing tease at
the end of metroid prime well metroid
prime 2 echoes continues on the
faison-centric narrative of the original
prime relocating the action to the
planet of aether which has gone through
a similar tragedy to that scene with the
chozo on talon 4. the game kicks off
with samus arriving on aether after
responding to a distress call from squad
bravo a team of galactic federation
marines who have been marooned on the
planet after chasing down some space
pirates samus crash lands on the planet
and soon finds the remnants of squad
bravo in an extended opening sequence
that riffs heavily on james cameron's
1986 action masterpiece aliens
as samus delves further into aether she
soon discovers a strange being that
resembles herself this is of course the
very same entity that we saw at the end
of the original primes post-credits
scene this dark samus attacks our bounty
hunter which once again removes every
ability we learned in the previous prime
game and thus sets the need to find
everything again
ah video games samus begins to explore
her surroundings and makes her way into
the great temple where she meets umos
one of the last of a race of aliens
known as the luminoff umos explains the
strange situation behind aether
revealing that a meteor once crashed
into the planet and the resulting energy
from the impact opened up a dimensional
rift which spawned an entirely separate
planet that exists in a parallel
dimension a planet that brought with it
bug-like warriors the ing
and so the main bulk of ekko sees samus
exploring the remnants of the planet and
its dark twin on a mission to restore
the once peaceful planet back to its
former and singular glory naturally dark
samus gets in the way of this mission
picking a fight with regular samus not
once not twice but three times
before the mission is done after the
final feud dark samus finally
disintegrates into a cloud of phason
particles but don't you worry this isn't
the last we'll see of this trixie
doppelganger samus eventually completes
her mission restoring the light power to
aether and destroying the ing population
all before dark aether collapses in on
itself but wait if you 100 of the game
yet again you would have seen another
little post credits tease showing that
cloud of faison reforming into dark
samus which leads us right into
the prime trilogy's finale metroid prime
3 corruption picks up the narrative six
months later and kicks off when samus
and three other bounty hunters are
recruited by the galactic federation to
investigate a network corruption to one
of their outlying planets to absolutely
nobody's surprise it's dark samus and
the space pirates behind the dirty work
and samus and co head to the planet
norion to fend them off upon arrival the
federation discovers that another
meteorite is on course to impact norian
in a similar manner to both talonfor and
aether before it bit of a pattern
emerging here lads samus's batch of
bounty hunters managed to destroy the
incoming meteorite but they are ambushed
by dark samus who corrupts them all with
faison
fast forward a month and samus has been
rehabilitated with a fancy new power
suit known as the ped suit which allows
her to harness the power of faison on
the flip side it's corrupting her slowly
so swings and roundabouts eh the
federation gives samus a new mission
destroy the remaining faison meteorites
and search for her missing bounty hunter
mates who have all gone off the grid
while following similar orders this
mission takes samis to three new worlds
bryo elisia and the pirate homeworld
where she encounters the other hunters
and learns that they have all fallen
foul to the phase on corruption forcing
samus to make the executive decision to
put them out of their misery
upon destroying all faison on the three
aforementioned planets samus's mission
eventually leads her to faze a sentient
planet which is the source of all the
phase on across the previous three games
and the trilogy's one true antagonist if
you think hard enough about it
there samus encounters and destroys dark
samus once and for all before destroying
phase itself and as a result all the
known faison across the universe
naturally as has become custom for the
series if you got 100 completion you
were treated to a quick post-credit
sting which saw samus jet off into the
cosmos in her gunship but wait what's
that sneaky ship following her well back
at e3 2015 metroid prime series producer
ken tsuke tanabe confirmed that the
owner of this snazzy spacecraft was the
bounty hunter silex who we first met in
metroid prime hunters
[Music]
while the destruction of faison
naturally made for the perfect ending
for the prime sub series nintendo had
other ideas
and so we have metroid prime federation
force bludgeoning its way into this
timeline and it makes for quite a unique
detour in the metroid franchise for
starters samus takes a back seat in the
game so you take up control of the
titular federation force a group of
mech-suited marines who are tasked with
eliminating the space pirate threat in
the wake of the events of metroid prime
3. as federation force was largely an
action-focused co-op game there's not a
whole load of meaningful narrative beats
but there's a few things worth
mentioning the game takes the force to
the bermuda system where they find space
pirate activity on the planet of
talvania after fending them off they
hire samus to investigate the pirates
activity on the planet which kind of
feels like they're passing the buck but
who am i to judge naturally samus does
all the dirty work and finds clues that
lead to a space pirate weapon named the
doom's eye which sounds cheery after
locating the doom's eye the force
infiltrates it and kills the master
brain think mother brain but more
derivative before being bailed out by
samus yet again when the doom's eye is
destroyed bringing federation force to a
close but wait if you nab the metroid
egg during the infestation mission you
were treated to another cameo from
bounty hunter silex this time breaking
into the federation facility before
stealing the egg and hatching it
are these two cameos foreshadowing silex
as the big bad at metroid prime 4
theorise away
right after that lengthy detour into the
metroid prime subseries we're finally on
to metroid
two
the galactic federation have finally
decided that they've had enough of
metroid's thank you very much and have
sent in a crack team of marines to
exterminate the little parasites on
their home world of sr-388 as you might
have already guessed those marines
failed but not before sending some
research data back that confirms the
presence of metroids within the planet's
core enter samus again to clean up the
federation's mess and put an end to the
alien parasites threat once and for all
and that's pretty much the plot of
metroid 2 in its remake samus returns
samus basically goes around
systematically hunting and then killing
every metroid left on the planet they
largely take the form of weird alien
crustacean things but as samus delves
deep into sr-388 they've become
increasingly larger and more violent
after eliminating the metroids and their
queen samus encounters a metroid egg
which hatches right in front of her
unable to kill the little baby metroid
who imprints on samus like she's the
mother samus takes the little lad back
to the surface on the surface the pair
attacked yet again by our old pal ridley
now in new proteus flavor samus has
dispatched ridley more times than she's
had hot dinners though and with the help
of her little metroid mate sees off the
rotten lizard once again samus and her
new baby metroid jet off into the stars
but in a post-credits scene we get our
first glimpse of the x parasite the
original apex predator of sr-388
yes the metroid franchise just went a
little deeper
in fact metroid samus returns actually
dropped something of a shocking
bombshell for the franchise in the new
chozo memories gallery we learned that
the chozo came to sr-388 and discovered
the potential threat of the x-parasite
then and here's the big bombshell they
created the metroids themselves to
counter the x-parasites only things
didn't quite work out that well the
metroids latched themselves to well
everything
sensing the doom they had brought upon
themselves the chozo attempted to seal
the metroids within the bowels of the
planet before fleeing to the surface
when they got there they were greeted by
a rescue party
who promptly murdered them all and make
sure to remember this arm cannon
sporting chozo lad as it looks like
he'll be cropping back up in metroid
dread
next up we have the absolute stone cold
classic that is super metroid or metroid
3 if you're going by the numbering of
this topsy-turvy franchise by now
metroid's are on the brink of extinction
save for our little baby pal from the
last game who we catch up with in the
title card cute things go downhill from
here fast though having delivered the
baby metro to the galactic federation
scientist samus heads off to hunt
another bounty only to have to double
back on herself when the research center
she was just in calls out for help samus
hightails it back to the labs only to
find ridley nicking her little metroid
mate before the giant lizard escapes
back to his old stomping ground of zebes
yep that's right we are heading back to
where this all started samus follows and
lands on the old chozo homeworld only to
discover the space pirates have rebuilt
their colony in the years since her last
adventure here samus once again dives
into the underbelly of zebes hunting and
killing the space pirates and their
generals including the big fat dragon
thing crade once again until she
encounters a giant metroid who drains
her of all her life energy just as she's
about to die the metroid stops leeching
her as it finally recognizes who it's
munching on turns out that the baby
metroid she found got swole samus
revives herself and confronts a
resurrected mother brain who has once
again masterminded the whole space
pirate enterprise as the battle ensues
the swole metroid swings by to help
samus out sucking power from mother
brain and giving it to samus in a
pivotal make or break moment for the
bounty hunter for its trouble it is
executed by mother brain
and this act of violence sends samus on
a devastating war path and she avenges
her baby by destroying mother brain once
and for all before fleeing the crumbling
remains of zebes the events of super
metroid have a lot of repercussions
within the franchise the space pirates
are finally finished the metroids are
effectively extinct the chozo homeworld
of zebes is wiped from the galaxy and
samus is left with a whole heap of
problems chief among them a diagnosis of
post-traumatic stress disorder which
drives a large chunk of the narrative of
our next game and boy is there a lot of
narrative in that next game
[Music]
metroid other m which was developed in
conjunction with team ninja puts a heavy
emphasis on narrative with an extensive
amount of cutscenes in the wake of the
events of super metroid samus is put
into rehabilitation by the galactic
federation and fair play because by this
point she's been through a lot coming
out of rehab samus gets back to bounty
hunting and soon receives a distress
signal that leads her to an old
abandoned federation horn called the
bottle ship only upon further
investigation it's not abandoned as
samus soon encounters the seventh
platoon and her old federation
ringleader adam malkovich malkovich
malkovich
malkovich malkovich malkovich
malkovich malkovich
samus agrees to cooperate with their old
squad mates and as they investigate the
battleship they uncover a mystery that
hints at corruption within the galactic
federation itself why well it only
bloody turns out that a group of
scientists have cloned ridley and the
metroids turns out that while samus was
in rehab galactic federation scientists
were able to extract metroid particles
from her power suit as a result with the
baby metroid fusing itself with her at
the end of super metroid with this new
metroid dna scientists used the
bottleship as a research facility for
turning the titular parasites into
bioweapons because at this stage nobody
has learned anything from the history of
these volatile creatures there's a whiff
of adam malkovich being in on the
corruption but those notions are put to
bed when malkovich sacrifices himself to
destroy the sector containing the
recreated metroids samus pleads with him
to reconsider but she eventually
reluctantly agrees and honors his memory
by destroying the metroid queen and thus
exterminating the race all over again
and so we reached the penultimate game
in the franchise metroid fusion pulling
on narrative threads from both other m
and samus returns metroid fusion sees
samus escort a research team back to
sr-388
where she's infected by the x parasite
that we saw in the post-credit sting if
metroid samus returns while she's fine
at first the parasite slowly overwhelms
her immune system causing her to crash
her trusty gunship into an asteroid belt
samus is saved by the galactic
federation and a team of doctors had to
surgically remove parts of her power
suit from her ex-parasite-riddled body
she is then cured of her disease with a
vaccine made from her little metroid pal
that metroid's looking out for his
surrogate mum from beyond the grave what
a top lad samus eventually recovers from
the virus and renewed with immunity to
the ex-parasite she's dispatched to the
biologic space laboratory's research
station that's a mouthful to investigate
a series of disturbances linked to her
old x-parasite infested power suit upon
arriving at the bsl station samus
discovers said suit roaming around like
some kind of metal zombie and this
zombie power suit is dubbed the sax by
samus's computerized co who's actually
the disembodied voice of adam malkovich
samus continues to explore the research
station eventually encountering another
lab containing metroid specimens and
with the further discovery that there's
actually 10 saxs on the space station
apparently they can asexually reproduce
or something samus makes the wise call
to initiate the station's self-destruct
function and crash it into the planet of
sr-388 and as samus escapes into the
stars again the station plummets down to
the surface of sr-388 destroying it and
the x parasite forever probably
[Music]
all of which leads us to metroid dread
which puts a nice neat bow on samus's
seemingly never-ending mission to
exterminate the metroids turns out for
all her hard work in metroid fusion some
form of the x parasite lived on in the
far-flung waste of the planet of zdr
keen to eradicate the pests the galactic
federation dispatched seven
devastatingly powerful robots the extra
planetary multi-form mobile identifiers
or emmys for sure no not those naturally
the emmys promptly go missing under
mysterious circumstances and samus being
the only known being in the universe
who's immune to the x parasite is sent
to find out why and the rest of metroid
dread as of now remains a mystery there
are a few more details that we do know
however chief among them the presence of
the chozo including the power cannon
sporting lad we clocked back in the
chozo memories from metroid samus
returns amazingly this marks the first
time the chozo themselves have actually
appeared in a metroid game and they look
like they mean business and the other
key thing to note is that this is the
end of a story arc 35 years in the
making a story arc that will finally see
some closure for samus and her lifelong
quest to exterminate the metroids but
crucially it's not the end of samus's
story which will hopefully continue on
whenever we finally get details about
the upcoming metroid prime 4.
and that pauses the metroid timeline
explained well up to and including the
early stages of metroid dread at least
if you like these extensive gaming
timelines please like this video and let
us know what you'd like to see in the
comments below we've already got an
extensive timeline of the resident evil
franchise if you're a fan of that mad
series thanks for watching guys and i'll
catch you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you